So imagine your father suddenly forgets who you are.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, he just starts hallucinating.
He can't string a coherent sentence together.
And I mean, your absolute first instinct,
the terror that just immediately grips you,
is that his brain is fundamentally failing.
Right. You think it's permanent.
Exactly. You think you're witnessing this permanent, irreversible cognitive collapse.
But what if I told you the actual culprit behind that entire terrifying scenario
is just a minor bladder infection?
It just completely upends how we intuitively think about brain health, doesn't it?
Totally.
Because we tend to view cognitive decline as this purely structural isolated brain issue,
when in reality, the brain is constantly at the mercy of the systemic environment that sits inside.
Which is, well, it's the core mission of our deep dive today.
We're unpacking this highly intensive clinical prep guide.
It's called Pass Ready Prep.
And it's basically a medical roadmap for practitioners.
A very dense roadmap, I might add.
Oh, incredibly dense.
But it's designed to help them navigate the really murky waters of neurocognitive disorders.
So the goal for you listening today is to decode these clinical signatures.
We are going to isolate exactly how medical professionals separate a temporary,
reversible physiological crisis from, well, a permanent neurological decline.
And having this framework is just, it's essential.
Because these aren't just academic distinctions.
The differential diagnosis here represents a literal test in line for survival.
Right.
The diagnostic criteria we're looking at,
they basically serve as a guardrail against catastrophic medical assumptions.
Okay, let's unpack this.
Because the clinical framework consists that before any long-term neurological assessment
can even begin, like before a doctor even entertains the word Alzheimer's,
there's this massive immediate fork in the road.
Yes, the big one.
It's the strict separation between delirium and dementia.
And that separation is the absolute bedrock of acute neurological care.
Because if a clinician, or honestly even a family member, conflates those two states,
the resulting interventions, or I guess the lack of interventions, can be fatal.
Right, so let's visualize this using a mechanical analogy.
Because I think that helps.
Think of the human brain as this highly complex car engine, right?
Delirium is the flashing red check engine light on your dashboard.
I like that.
Yeah, it's an acute, immediate alert.
It's actively screaming that a critical failure is happening right this second
in an otherwise functioning system.
Dementia, conversely, represents the gradual structural wear and tear of the engine itself.
The long-term damage.
Exactly.
It's the piston ring slowly grinding down over like 80,000 miles.
You don't get a flashing alarm for that.
The engine just imperceptibly loses horsepower over a decade.
The real utility of that analogy, though, is that it dictates your immediate action.
How so?
Well, when the check engine light is flashing and the car is stalling out on the highway,
you don't just declare the engine permanently destroyed and send it off to the junkyard.
No, you'd pull over.
Exactly.
You pull over and you find the immediate disruption.
Delirium is a medical emergency because it is highly reversible.
It means there's a systemic crisis actively occurring in the body.
And resolving that crisis, you know, it turns the flashing red light off.
So for you listening, if a loved one or an aging parent experiences this sudden
drastic shift in their cognition, assuming it's just the inevitable result of,
quote unquote, getting older, is a profoundly dangerous cognitive bias.
It really is.
That sudden confusion is a biological alarm bell.
And missing that alarm bell is framed within the entire diagnostic community
as the ultimate clinical trap, which I guess brings us to
identifying the exact parameters of that flashing red light.
Right.
In standard clinical coding, this acute state is classified as delirium, code F05.
And its presentation has very, very specific boundaries.
And the primary boundary is the timeline, right?
Because the onset is incredibly acute.
We are talking hours to a few days.
Yes.
Very rapid.
Like someone is entirely lucid on Tuesday.
They're managing their finances.
And then by Thursday evening, they are completely disoriented to time and place.
That acute timeline is key.
But you also have to watch their presentation throughout the day.
Because the second definitive marker is a wildly fluctuating course.
The cognitive impairment waxes and wanes.
So it's not constant.
No, not at all.
A patient might be remarkably clear in the morning holding a totally nuanced conversation
and then severely decompensate by the late afternoon.
Oh, wow.
And the clinical data strongly indicates these fluctuations typically worsen at night.
It's a phenomenon often referred to colloquially as sun downing,
though the mechanism is purely physiological.
And the core deficit, and this is a vital distinction in the text,
isn't actually memory formation.
It's a fundamental collapse of attention and awareness.
The patient simply cannot lock onto an external stimulus or hold a train of thought.
Because you cannot encode a memory if your brain's attentional hardware is offline.
Their awareness of their environment is entirely fractured.
And the critical variable driving this fracture is almost always extracranial.
Meaning, it is caused by a systemic medical insult outside the brain.
Like the standard culprits, the prep materials list.
An infection, an adverse medication reaction,
a severe metabolic derangement, or substance intoxication and withdrawal.
Yeah, a urinary tract infection, or a UTI, is the textbook example in geriatric populations.
But even a slight deviation in, say, serum sodium levels,
or the introduction of a new antihypertensive medication, that can trigger the exact same cascade.
Wait, I need to push back on how this actually looks in practice.
Okay, go for it.
If this condition fluctuates throughout the day and it heavily biases toward worsening at night,
couldn't a family or even a rushed triage nurse
easily misinterpret this as the patient just being overly tired?
Oh, easily.
Right. Or cranky.
I mean, how does a doctor definitively look at an elderly patient
who seems sleepy and irritated at 8 p.m. and recognize,
oh, this is an acute medical emergency?
What's fascinating here is how the biology of systemic stress
actually bypasses our traditional understanding of fatigue.
Okay.
On the surface, yes, it mimics extreme tiredness.
But biologically, an infection like a UTI generates a massive inflammatory cascade.
The body produces all these inflammatory cytokines to fight the bacteria.
Right, an immune response.
Exactly.
Now, in a younger resilient brain, the blood-brain barrier keeps those cytokines out.
But in an aging nervous system, that barrier is highly permeable.
So the systemic inflammation essentially breaches the wall.
Precisely.
Those cytokines cross the blood-brain barrier,
and they directly attack the brain's reticular activating system.
The reticular activating system.
Yeah, which is this deeply embedded neural network
responsible for filtering sensory information and maintaining our baseline wakefulness and attention.
The inflammation literally short-circuits that specific network.
Wow.
So the brain acts as an ultra-sensitive barometer for systemic physiological stress.
It's not fatigue.
It's a neuro-inflammatory blockade of the very hardware required to stay conscious.
That completely reframes the entire condition.
So you clear the bacteria in the bladder, the cytokine storm subsides,
the blood-brain barrier stabilizes,
and the reticular activating system just comes back online.
Exactly.
The cognitive fog literally lifts.
That is the mandate.
You must always clear the systemic variables first
because you can actively reverse the impairment.
Which brings us to the next diagnostic phase.
Let's assume the clinical team has run the complete metabolic panels,
they've cultured the urine, rigorously audited every medication.
The acute stuff is ruled out.
Right.
The acute fluctuating crisis of delirium is definitively off the table.
Now, the diagnostic landscape shifts entirely to the long-term structural integrity of the brain.
The permanent conditions.
These are the major and mild neurocognitive disorders,
which were formally broadly categorized as the dementias.
And the diagnostic threshold between mild and major is remarkably pragmatic.
It doesn't hinge on complex neuroimaging.
It hinges on the concept of independence.
Yeah.
It's a functional line of demarcation rather than a strictly biological one.
The assessment evaluates the patient's capacity to navigate instrumental activities of daily living.
So, like, everyday tasks.
If there's measurable cognitive decline,
maybe it's showing up on standardized memory tests,
but the individual can still independently manage their finances,
prepare their own meals safely, navigate their community without supervision,
then it is classified as a mild neurocognitive disorder.
But the moment the cognitive deficit breaches the threshold
and requires constant intervention or compensatory strategies from others
to ensure safety like when they leave the stove on
or they can no longer comprehend their medication schedule,
it formally becomes a major neurocognitive disorder.
And once that functional threshold is crossed into a major disorder,
the clinical focus becomes identifying that specific etiology.
Because the exact type of structural failure
dictates the entire trajectory of the disease,
and they present fundamentally differently.
Well, the text highlights Alzheimer's disease as the most prevalent.
And the onset here is described as incredibly insidious,
predominantly targeting short-term memory first.
Insidious perfectly captures the pathology.
It is driven by the microscopic accumulation of amyloid plaques outside the neurons
and towel protein tangles inside them.
The classic markers.
Right.
And this pathological burden begins in the temporal lobes,
specifically attacking the hippocampus, long before any clinical symptoms even appear.
And since the hippocampus governs the consolidation of new memories,
the inability to retain recent information is the leading indicator.
Exactly.
Returning to our vehicle analogy,
Alzheimer's operates like an imperceptibly slow leak in a tire.
The air pressure drops so gradually
that you don't even register the change on a daily basis.
You just keep driving.
Yeah.
The early stages are just slight deflations,
misplacing items, repeating anecdotes,
until one day you realize the car is driving entirely on the rim.
It's a seamless, continuous downward slope.
But contrast that with vascular neurocognitive disorder,
where the structural damage is driven by cerebrovascular disease,
the clinical presentation here is a stepwise decline.
So instead of a smooth, gradual deflation,
vascular dementia operates like descending a staircase.
Yes, exactly.
You walk along a relatively stable cognitive plateau for months,
and then you abruptly drop down a step,
losing a noticeable degree of cognitive function overnight.
And then you plateau again at that lower level until the next sudden drop.
And those sudden drops correspond to distinct vascular events.
We're talking about micro infarcts,
these tiny ischemic strokes deep within the brain's white matter.
A small blood vessel becomes occluded,
a specific region of neural tissue is starved of oxygen and dies,
and the cognitive function tied to that tissue just vanishes instantly.
It's a brutal progression.
But structurally, it forces the clinician to become a medical historian.
You weren't just evaluating their memory performance today,
you were interrogating their cardiovascular past.
Right, because a diagnosis of vascular neurocognitive disorder
is heavily reliant on a history of hypertension,
hyperlipidemia, maybe poorly managed diabetes,
or previous transient ischemic attacks.
So the pathology in the brain is merely the endpoint
of systemic vascular disease that has been compounded for decades.
Spot on.
But neurological decline rarely adheres to the neat,
memory-centric narratives we expect.
And the diagnostic framework pivots sharply here
to conditions that actively defy everything society thinks it knows
about what dementia looks like.
Yeah, these specific etiologies frequently blindside families.
Because the initial presentation involves zero memory loss,
which leads to severe misinterpretations of the patient's behavior.
And here's where it gets really interesting.
Because frontotemporal neurocognitive disorder
completely shatters the stereotype.
The onset typically occurs significantly earlier, often in a patient's 50s.
Much younger than people expect.
Right, and the defining feature is
that memory and visuospatial skills are heavily spared early on.
The deterioration happens exclusively in behavior, personality, and language.
Which makes sense from a neuroanatomical perspective.
The frontal lobes govern executive function,
so our impulse control, empathy, social tack, complex decision making.
The things that make us us.
Exactly.
As the localized atrophy destroys those specific regions,
the biological filter that dictates societal behavior just evaporates.
Which means a highly successful 55-year-old executive
might suddenly start making wildly inappropriate comments in public,
or demonstrating extreme apathy toward their spouse,
or even impulsively liquidating their retirement accounts.
And their family is understandably devastated.
Of course, they often interpret it as a midlife crisis,
or a psychiatric break, or just profound selfishness.
Because if you take that same individual
and administer a standard memory test, they will score perfectly.
They know exactly who they are, where they are, and what they had for breakfast.
The tragedy of frontotemporal disease is that
the fundamental architecture of their personality deteriorates
long before the cognitive mechanisms required to perceive that deterioration fail.
It redefines the devastation of cognitive loss.
I mean, you aren't losing the timeline of your life.
You're losing the emotional hardware that allows you to participate in it.
Well said.
Then, the framework introduces Lewy Body Disease.
And this is where the symptomatology becomes incredibly complex.
The clinical triad for Lewy Body is fluctuating cognition,
highly detailed visual hallucinations, and spontaneous Parkinsonism,
meaning physical tremors and muscle rigidity.
Right.
And the pathology here is driven by the abnormal aggregation
of a protein called alpha-synuclein.
The Lewy Bodies.
Yes.
These clumps distribute widely across the cerebral cortex and the substantia nigra,
so they're simultaneously ravaging the brain's sensory processing centers
and its motor control pathways.
Okay, I have to pause and challenge this framework
based on what we established earlier.
Let's hear it.
The text explicitly states Lewy Body involves fluctuating cognition,
characterized by profound variations in attention and alertness.
That sounds identical to the acute delirium we discussed in the very beginning.
It does.
So how does a clinician differentiate between
a systemic infection causing delirium and the onset of Lewy Body Disease
when the attentional deficits look exactly the same?
If we connect this to the bigger picture,
you have just identified the single most perilous diagnostic tightrope in geriatric neurology.
Really?
Oh, absolutely.
The fluctuating attention in Lewy Body Disease is virtually indistinguishable from delirium.
The differentiation relies entirely on the presence of the other two pillars.
Hallucinations in the tremors?
Right.
The recurrent, well-formed visual hallucinations,
often patients report silently watching people or animals in the room
and that physical motor stiffness.
But why is misidentifying that fluctuation so dangerous?
If a doctor assumes it's just severe delirium
or maybe late-onset schizophrenia because the patient is hallucinating,
what is the actual consequence?
It leads to the most severe safety warning in the entire clinical text.
Severe neuroleptic sensitivity.
Neuroleptic sensitivity.
Yeah. See, the standard psychiatric reflex to treat severe distressing hallucinations
is to administer an antipsychotic medication.
And antipsychotics work by blocking dopamine receptors in the brain.
But Lewy Body patients are already experiencing massive dopamine deficits
due to the damage in their motor pathways.
Exactly. So the sensitivity is catastrophic.
If you administer a typical antipsychotic to a Lewy Body patient,
it further depletes their critically low dopamine levels.
Oh, no.
This can trigger an irreversible, profound physical decline.
The patient can become locked in severe muscular rigidity,
they lose the ability to swallow,
and they can experience fatal autonomic nervous system crashes.
That's terrifying.
A single dose of the wrong medication
based on a misdiagnosis of their hallucinations can be lethal.
So the requirement to categorize these conditions accurately
isn't just about giving the family a name for the disease.
It's an active defensive measure
to protect the patient from standard medical interventions
that would otherwise kill them.
Exactly.
The diagnostic label dictates the contraindicated treatments
just as much as the recommended ones.
So what does this all mean?
Once a clinician has successfully navigated this minefield,
identified this specific ideology,
and bypassed the contraindications,
what does the actual treatment protocol look like?
Well, the clinical guidelines establish a very structured holistic baseline.
First, optimize the environment to ensure physical safety
and minimize disorientation.
Okay.
Second, aggressively treat any reversible overlapping conditions.
If a patient has advanced Alzheimer's,
their baseline is already compromised,
which means they are hyper susceptible to developing delirium
from a minor infection.
So you have to constantly guard against those superimposed crises.
Exactly.
The text mentions pharmacological interventions too,
like cholinesterase inhibitors for Alzheimer's,
which attempt to boost neurotransmitter levels to modestly delay symptom progression.
But the most profound mandate in the entire treatment protocol
isn't actually directed at the patient at all.
No, it's not.
It's the requirement to actively assess and support the caregiver.
It is a totally unique medical paradigm.
I mean, in oncology or cardiology,
the treatment is heavily biologically centered on the patient.
But with major neurocognitive disorders,
the disease happens to the brain of the patient,
but the collateral damage happens to the psychological
and physiological health of the family.
The literature on caregiver burden is staggering.
The chronic hypervigilance required to keep a wandering patient safe,
the constant emotional mourning of someone
who is still physically sitting in the room with you.
I mean, it generates a massive allostatic load.
The caregiver's cortisol levels remain perpetually elevated.
And the clinical reality is that a burned out,
sleep deprived, medically compromised caregiver
simply cannot maintain the safe environment
required for the patient's survival.
Right.
Therefore, intervening to provide respite care,
psychological support, and education to the family
is not some secondary consideration.
It is a primary medical intervention
for the disease itself.
Because we lack the pharmacological tools
to halt the underlying neurological decay,
we can only engineer the safest possible descent.
Which circles us directly back to the ultimate
clinical warning embedded in this framework.
The absolute worst case scenario
that every medical professional is trained to fear.
The phenomenon of delirium superimposing itself
on existing dementia.
It is the most common and most frequently missed clinical trap.
Yeah.
Well, we want to thank you for exploring
this highly complex medical architecture with us.
Yeah.
Understanding this diagnostic framework
fundamentally shifts how you perceive cognitive health.
It transforms a terrifying, opaque process
into a structured, navigable map.
You now understand the profound differences
between structural decay and systemic crisis.
But as you digest these clinical signatures,
consider a final thought that extends beyond the pathology itself.
Yeah.
We discussed how a simple, localized infection like a UTI
can generate enough systemic inflammation
to breach the blood-brain barrier,
shut down the reticular activating system,
and completely dissolve a person's conscious awareness
and attention.
It erases their ability to interact with reality.
And if they already have dementia,
everyone just assumes it's the disease progressing, right?
But it forces us to ask a deeply unsettling question
about the nature of human consciousness itself.
If our awareness, our attention, and our ability
to hold on to our very identity can be so easily dismantled
by a routine immune response to bacteria,
how much of who we are is actually a fixed, permanent trait?
Wow.
And how much of our core identity
is merely a fragile illusion,
existing entirely at the momentary mercy
of our immune system?
It suggests that our consciousness is far less permanent
than we'd like to believe.
It's a sobering reminder to pay deep, continuous attention
to the subtle physiological shifts
in the people we care about.
Stay curious, stay vigilant,
and we will catch you on the next deep dive.